welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and you didn't see that coming did you
well you probably did if you watched the
leaks
but like me i can imagine that a lot of
you were still mind blown by the big
reveal that the mcu is now crossing the
multiverse
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down some of the big questions
giving our theories on what's going on
and a lot more
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
episode 5 of one division then i suggest
you take it from the top and go and
watch it please click the thumbs up
button if you enjoy the video
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is why monica's readings are not
showing up on the chart
if you already know the answer then the
time codes are below
but we pretty much know that she's now
going to be exactly in line with her
comic book counterpart
in the marvel universe she's a superhero
who goes under the pseudonym photon
which is of course the nickname that her
mother had in the air force
photon has several powers and abilities
and can fly
fire powerful boats and also change her
appearance
this skilled set has of course been
demonstrated in the hex
especially the shape-shifting that we've
seen not only in the environment
but also the characters themselves
monica is the only one other than wanda
who has left the hex
it's likely that when she was tossed out
the membrane
mixed with the reality stone powers that
were enveloping her
changed her physiology now in the
promotional posters for the show
we can actually see what looks like it
might be photons uniform
this black and white costume likely
highlights that monica will be donning
it at some point
and she may even return to the hex when
it's fully modernized
and be given this uniform upon entering
as for sword in general
they seem a lot more nefarious the more
we learn about them
i think we're starting to get more of an
idea of what it is exactly that they're
doing
during the briefing scene acting
director hayward states that vision said
in his will that he was not to be turned
into a weapon
however in the cctv footage we can see a
lot of people in lab coats experimenting
on him
and they could have actually been going
against his wishes
wanda demonstrates amnesia over what
happened before west view
and it is possible that she was actually
stopping them from salvaging parts from
her husband to make a doomsday device
we know that under hayward's direction
that sort of stopped looking to the
stars
and their mission statement has changed
to focus more on worldly problems
therefore they could also be developing
weapons similar to what shield were
doing in the avengers
though we did theorize that hayward is
actually mephisto in another video that
you should definitely check out
there is another theory that comes from
yash arya he pointed out that
using the letters of hayward's name you
can spell out hydra
and the villainous organization have
been laced throughout wonders past
and of course this series perhaps they
never stop spying on her
and though it would be a bit cliche they
may have infiltrated sword in the same
way that they snuck into shield
that is of course just a theory but
there are a lot of red flags when it
comes to hayward
monica was of course supposed to ascend
to being the director of the
organization
but because she was snapped she was
unable to fill the shoes of her mother
and thus he has stepped in and derailed
the agency quite a lot
he may of course be a misdirect but i
still feel like
something more sinister is going on with
him though the episode seems to be
pointing
all guns at wonder literally i don't
think she's the one doing it at all
in the closing scene of the episode
before quicksilver arrives
she asks if vision really thinks that
she's the one behind it
and can't even remember how she got
there wanda states that if she was
running it all
then she'd have to make sure that people
go to dentist appointments and so on
which definitely feels out of her range
of abilities
there is a moment in the entry when
vision snaps norm out of the hypnosis
for a second
and he heavily implies that she's behind
it all however he never says wonder
and if we just take the word she it
could apply to both agnes and dottie
the former seems to know exactly what's
going on in the town
due to her awareness of taking things
from the top and the latter of course
runs things in west view we know
westview doesn't have any children in it
either and shout outs to rohit matayani
for pointing out that agnes said
kids can't be controlled though she was
just talking about billy and tommy in
general
i think this shows that she is aware of
the mechanics of the hex itself
and what can and can't be done there
children are likely not in it because
they would blow the lid on the entire
thing
and this little line of dialogue does
highlight what's going on
thus i think wonder is not really doing
it at all she's just being set up as a
patsy so that she can be taken out by
sword or the avengers and the real
villains can swoop in and steal her kids
hide your wife hide your kids because
agnes seems to have her eyes on them
and personally i believe that wonder
went to her as a way to learn how to
improve her abilities
agnes likely is tied in with the dark
lord mephisto himself
and thus the pair may have decided to
create a reality that would convince
wander to have children in order to take
them
because of their parents they would be
extremely powerful
and thus if given the right guidance
they could help the pair take over the
world
children were clearly subliminally
planted into wander's head
and if you watch episode 2 with the
thought process that the entire thing is
a setup to make her create them
then the episode itself has a much
deeper meaning
now as for how wonder brought vision
back to life
i don't think that she did at all when
it comes to the dog it's clear that
she's unable to resurrect the dead
and agnes even questions whether she has
the powers to reanimate its corpse
this line was clearly put in for a
reason i think that it hammers home the
idea that it was in fact someone else
now the work itself is based heavily
upon the vision and skull at which
graphic novel from 1985
which features the grim reaper his
helmet was also shown in episode 2
and it is possible that he was the
reason that vision was able to be
brought back from the dead
or they could have just charged his
batteries but you never know
now as for evan peters's quicksilver
arriving at the end
this of course carries a lot with it i
did have a couple of comments saying
that you could see mephisto's hand in
the window before he arrived
but if we look closely it's actually
just vision's purple head
reflecting in the glass not that kind of
purple head you dirty bad boy
anyway this is definitely quicksilver as
if you listen to the scene with the
audio description on
you will hear the narrator say that it's
the one from the x-men films
i kind of feel like what's happening
here is that wanda wished to have her
brother brought back
and she made a deal with the devil but
this has had a monkey's poor effect
and instead it's brought back the one
who wasn't dead aaron taylor johnson's
would of course be a rotten corpse at
this point
and thus it makes more sense to just
pluck one from another timeline
now i have seen some say that this might
actually be mephisto himself
and that could be the case however i
feel like feige is gonna be bringing
across a lot of the x-men from the other
franchises
and if he's doing this on a grand scale
he probably doesn't want to ruin the
first one with a fake out
and make it someone else i'm not going
to talk about the leaks for the next
episode in depth but if you've seen them
you'll know that quicksilver has quite a
smart mouth in it
and this reminded me a lot of the scene
in days of future past
in which he was kind of making jabs at
people every chance he could
now hex points have popped up at several
points in the mcu
and they are often used as a way to
travel through space
if we think of this on a grander scale
it could actually mean that they can be
used to travel across dimensions
and westview itself may indeed be a way
to bring all the fox characters across
i love how everyone has been asking
fergie if he's gonna recast the x-men
for years
and he's just been like no i don't think
i will
one day we might actually get that hugh
jackman return but
we will of course have to see now on top
of all this it is actually possible that
reed richards
aka the head of the fantastic four is
already in the mcu
monica mentioning that she knows an
aerospace engineer definitely fits the
bill of one of the richards
and this could mean that we will be
getting the first family of marvel
a lot sooner than we thought it was
theorized that they might be the
astronaut to drift in space
but monica's saying this actually makes
a lot more sense now it could easily be
su-2 or even maybe victor von doom
depending on how they handle the
character just thought i'd add that
that bit in the end there just before
kicks off now the tease towards them
came with monika discussing a way to get
back into the hex
and that you would be doing in a vehicle
which we know from the trailers does get
built
so a big character may even pop up very
soon
i just hope that the cast of phantom 4
stick aren't sat waiting for that call
from
feige their movie is of course coming
very soon
and john watts is actually going to
direct their first outing after he
finishes up spider-man 3.
so they are definitely on the court and
whilst i don't know if this will be read
or not
it is a cool little detail you know
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the theories
so if you have any then make sure you
comment below and let me know
i said thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 28th of february in which
we're giving away three copies of the
marvel phase 3 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the fifth episode which
will be linked on screen right now
i'll also leave the mephisto theory link
there if you want to check it out
as we cover a lot more ground than
what's in this one
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time yeah you take
care peace